what is going on everybody welcome back
to my youtube channel richard on data
and if this is your first time here my
name is richard
and this is the channel where we talk
about all things data
data science statistics and programming
so subscribe for all kinds of content
just like this if you haven't already
and hit that notification bell so you
never miss an update
this is another video in my our tutorial
series
many of the videos so far have focused
on uh
packages in the tidy verse with some of
the newer videos getting into
statistical modeling because you need to
be familiar with
the lm glm functions how to exactly run
these things
understand what exactly you're getting
and then how do you actually interpret
those results
well in all these tutorials so far i've
been
walking you through our markdown uh
documents where
i've got all my code up here and i've
got all my commentary here
but i haven't exactly walked you through
our markdown
itself now personally i'm a huge fan of
our markdown
i like it better than jupiter notebooks
even just because
it's super easy to use it's super
streamlined and it just keeps
everything that you need your code your
results your commentary
everything all in one place so what
we're going to do in this tutorial
is we're going to walk through this rmd
file you're going to see
exactly how to set up exactly the kind
of document that you want to create
you're going to see exactly what the
knitted version of this looks like
and then before we break we are going to
look at the r markdown cheat sheet
because it's super easy to use
definitely something that i encourage
you to be familiar with
so before we get started number one
smash the like button for the youtube
algorithm
uh this code is going to be available on
my github repo
as usual that's going to be linked in
the description
uh i will say with this tutorial it
takes some influence from chapter 27 of
the book
r for data science by hadley wickham and
garrett grolimund
so highly recommend checking that out as
well and then lastly
i'll have a link in the description of
this video to my patreon account
and if you guys would be willing to
support me over there it would be
enormously appreciated
all right so we're literally going to
start here with line number one
and you'll notice the very first things
that we have in this file here
are information like your title author
date and then this output information
well and then all this information is
sandwiched between these dash dash
dashes
so this header at the top is what's
known as the yaml
header yaml stands for yamo
ain't markup language which i guess
technically it isn't it's a header
um the thing i want to draw attention to
actually is this
output followed by html document
followed by code folding uh show
so i always like concluding with this
code folding
show thing here because whenever you
have
a code inside of your actual uh
output you're gonna have a hide button
on the side
so you can toggle once you get your
actual uh knitted file
whether you want to show the code or
just the results
and you're gonna see that when i show
you the file here in a little bit
but we start up here with this yaml
header
and what you basically have inside of
any sort of markdown
uh document is three distinct components
number one is that yaml header number
two
are these code chunks and these are
sandwiched between that tilde tilde
tilde going on up here
and then you just have your text which
just which just provides your commentary
granted yes you can provide actual
comments
on the side over here like i'm going to
just type a comment here
and you can provide the commentary that
way but
you can actually see the commentary and
write it in a sort of way that
an audience can digest in report form
uh inside here outside the code chunks
then when you want to actually run these
code chunks
hit these green play buttons on the side
and then bam we're running code
now the text is often where you're going
to have the most fun here
because in the text you can utilize
markdown syntax
so i'm going to show you a few examples
here of what i tend to use the most
so for bold text you can put double
stars on each side of the text
or you can put double underscores on
each side of the text for italics you
can use
one single star on each side of the text
or
a single underscore then for superscript
let's suppose as a superscript i want to
have uh just a two so i basically want
this to say
superscript squared well i can create a
carrot symbol on each side of the two
we're going to see what this looks like
in a in a second here
uh for subscript it's a very similar
procedure
you can just put a little curly uh
tilde on each side of like a zero i want
the zero to be the uh to be the
subscript
uh for strikethrough text you can put
the uh
double uh curly tilde here
and then if you wanna embed a link so
what i'm going to do
is i'm going to create brackets here
and now i want the link here to go to
www.rstudio.com
but i just want the text here to say
link
so just the brackets link on the outside
lit the actual url that we're going to
uh
after that in parentheses now let's
actually look at the
output here and let's take a look at
what this is going to look like
so as promised up here you've got
the yaml header you've got the name that
i gave it our tutorial 0
12 r markdown richard on data followed
by the date
and then up here you have code show all
code
versus hidal code but you can do this
individually on each of these code
chunks as well so if i want to hide this
bam i can do that and so as promised
with
uh with this markdown syntax text here
i've got bold text and bold text italics
text and italics text
the superscript squared the subscript
not the strikethrough text and then the
embedded links
such as this link which actually goes to
our studio
now if you want to create white space
inside the document i typically do this
if i'm moving from section to section
and i'm using a lot of headers
you can do this uh br character
uh with the less than and greater than
signs around it
uh if you want to create a block quote
for any reason
you do uh the greater than sign followed
by the actual block
quote on a new line or alternatively if
you want to create a faint horizontal
rule
you can do this triple star sort of
thing once again
i'm going to go back to the output in a
minute here and you get to see exactly
what this looks like
but then another thing you're going to
want to be familiar with are the headers
and so we're going to create these with
the with the pound signs
and now this is counter-intuitive if
you're learning markdown syntax for the
first time
uh but the fewer pound signs that you
use
the bigger the header that you're going
to create so
one is gonna give you the biggest then
two will give you the second biggest
etc etc now what's interesting is
uh you can go all the way to the fifth
biggest header and this is still going
to look bigger than your actual text
but once you get all the way to six uh
pound signs
this header is actually going to be
smaller than the text that it's the
header of
so let's take a look at this so
again with our white space we created
that
for the block quotes we actually created
that so
if you have some inspiring quote that
you want to uh
uh put inside your our markdown document
crack your whip
and then this faint horizontal rule uh
maybe a little bit difficult to see
but it's definitely there now as far as
the headers are concerned
look you've got your biggest header and
then it goes all the way down to where
you look at the fifth biggest header and
you see it's maybe a little bit bigger
than the text that follows it
uh but the smallest header is definitely
a little bit
uh smaller than the actual text here so
just use it if you need to use that for
some kind of stylistic purpose
moving on to some more super fun stuff
so if you want to embed
mathematical equations in line you can
do it
by simply putting dollar signs on each
side of the equation
now there's a little bit more syntax
that goes behind this and i'm going to
have a link in the description to
a nice cheat sheet and reference for
this kind of thing
particularly as it comes to creating
things like your alpha or your beta
characters or things like that which
happen in statistics all the time
but you'll notice if i drag my cursor
around this it's going to show
as it's eventually going to display
everybody's familiar with this equation
e equals m times c
squared so i put it in here as an
example
uh something amazing that you can also
do
is embed the output of our code
in line as well and you can do this uh
with this
character on each side of the thing that
you want to get outputted
so again you'll see it when i go back to
the document and show you the output
here
but in the sentence i want to say
for example the mean is so and so
well what it's going to do when this
document knits
uh this code here mean of the mt
cars data set the hp variable
specifically
that's going to get evaluated and that's
going to show up
directly inside of this paragraph so
this is going to save you a
ton of time if you're creating some kind
of report
uh and you have to run it all the time
with uh with different numbers or your
data is changing all the time
definitely get used to using this syntax
because it is going to save you
hours and hours of your life you can
create
uh lists and tables so for instance
let's say i want to create an unordered
list i'm going to create
uh stars up front so i'm going to have
item number one is an unordered list
i'm gonna follow with item number two
and then
uh i'm going to indent with a tab uh do
plus plus sub item one to sub item two
alternatively maybe i wanna do uh number
one
ordered list number two item number two
followed by sub item one and sub item
two i can do a syntax like
that and then if i want to create a
an actual table so this is not based on
any data or anything i just want to
create this
uh using just pure markdown syntax
you can do it in this sort of fashion
you create your headers space them out
create your content cells and just do it
like that
more on tables in a minute here because
naturally our markdown is going to
provide
us some some functionalities for those
based on your actual data
but let's take a look at what all this
stuff looked like
so we've got our equation here e equals
m times c squared that
chunk of code that i wanted to evaluate
in line
did actually evaluate for example the
mean is 146.6875
that sure beats uh actually writing this
manually and then making mistakes later
when you forget to change something
so then we've got a list can be created
like we've got
a little bullet bullet and then the sub
bullets
or one two and then the following sub
bullets there
and alternatively a table can be uh
created like this
now you'll see that this actual table
has been uh created here
uh but next what we're actually gonna
look at is
actually using this cable function so
i'm going to run the chunk of code at
line 90 here just to give you an idea of
what this looks like
run the head function of mt cars and you
have
an outputted table however our markdown
gives us this helpful function cable
and so i'm going to wrap the cable
function around
exactly the line of code that i called
before i'm going to run that and see
what that looks like instead
see notice you get this nicely formatted
table here instead
actually here it might not necessarily
look as good
but if we go to uh the actual output
notice it actually looks significantly
better
now there's a lot that can go out that
can go behind
formatting these tables for outputting
and that's the subject for its own
uh tutorial but there's a lot of super
helpful packages such as cable extra
uh pander format table that are gonna
make that super easy for you
so you may be left thinking now okay
this is awesome
but how in the world am i going to
memorize all this
well the nice thing about our markdown
is you really don't have to memorize
pretty much
anything because basically all of it is
on the cheat sheet
so that's the next thing that we're
going to look at now this is an
incredibly easy to use
cheat sheet that luckily has all the
information that you're going to want
all in one spot it's very comprehensive
so if we start on the left side here
with open file
this is how you'll get started in the
first place if you go
to the top under file then new file
then r markdown it's going to allow you
to set your yaml header right up
so you can plug your title your author
right in
and similarly uh you can set your output
now html is the default but you can also
do
a pdf or word then you'll be all ready
to go
basically all of the markdown that i
showed you can be found right here as a
reference
there's a few things i left out because
i don't personally use them as much
but any of the syntax that you would
want can be found here
you can choose your actual output inside
of the yaml header
and now it doesn't even necessarily need
to be a document it could be
a beamer slideshow or an io slides
presentation
it's very customizable
going down to number five here it will
walk you through
embedding code so with the inline code
or the code chunks
as i showed you before then you've got
these uh display
options here with eval equals false
and then echo equals false now the
options are actually one thing that i
really want to highlight
because this is not something i went
through quite as much inside the
document here
but these are options that you can set
up
either to the code chunk or globally
now you'll notice i actually do a few
things globally
where right up front i have this chunk
of code where i do
knitter opt chunk sets warning equals
false comma message equals false
that's what that's basically saying is
for every single
chunk of code warning equals false
and message equals false it's just a lot
more
uh compact than just writing warning
equals false and message equals false
every time here
but we have a variety of options there's
eval for whether to evaluate the code
and include its results
echo is whether to display code along
with its results
so on and so forth uh i don't like to
display
warnings or messages and the defaults to
those things are true
so up front i just change those things
to false
so those are your options then you can
render up here by
at the top of your header here just go
to
knit you can set knit html knit pdf
or knit word and then you're good to go
as long as there's no
problems inside of your code that just
don't make any sense and just throw
errors
you're going to have a proper uh knitted
outputs that you can then go back and
change or
share with whomever you need to share it
with now
there are a number of options here for
interactive uh documents as well as
publishing to
various sites those are subjects for
other tutorials particularly with
interactive docs
but when i do a uh tutorial on shiny in
the near future here you're gonna learn
how to do all of that stuff as well
so that about covers it for our markdown
again
really get used to working in our
markdown
because if you share documents like this
i'm telling you yours your stakeholders
your clients
or the people that you're working with
internally they're absolutely gonna love
this
put a little bit of work depending on
your you know personal preferences and
just the
uh standards that you have to live up to
into making this
look nice but it's so nice just to be
able to have
all the code as well as your commentary
and your output all in one location so
it tells a story
so i'm gonna leave you there thanks all
for watching this
video if you enjoyed it again hit the
like button or consider sharing this
video
then i'll see you all in the not so
distant future until then
richard on data